six conventions ont été signées ce
samedi 26 novembre lors de la deuxième
journée des états généraux sur les
violences faites aux femmes à la réunion
sakai plan interministériel plus
ambitieux que le précédent grâce à un
budget alloué sur trois ans d'oubli et
des moyens supplémentaires financier
puisque les moyens son doublé entre le
quatrième point le cinquième plan ses
122 millions d'euros de crédits et bien
entendu la réunion sera éligible à ces
crédits et le tissu associatif
réunionnais pourra continuer d'agir et
même avoir encore des moyens dévolus
particulièrement à leur travail
d'accompagnement plusieurs aspects ont
été abordés afin d'améliorer la prise en
charge des femmes victimes de violences
et leurs enfants tels que favoriser
l'accès au logement
augmenter le nombre de téléphones grand
danger mais aussi le nombre de
personnels formés pour prendre en charge
les victimes
nous avons signé une convention qui nous
engage et financièrement mais aussi qui
nous engage sur le partenariat déjà
actif mais que nous complétons par
exemple nous conte finançons avec l'état
la présence des travailleurs sociaux
dans les commissariats de police et dans
la gendarmerie
c'est aussi une mesure qui connaît un
vrai succès et qui a apporté des
réponses sur la prise en charge et
l'écoutent des femmes qui viennent
porter plainte par exemple offert une
main courante
tout le travail que nous menons aussi
pour faciliter dépôt de plainte la
conservation des preuves
et puis la réflexion nous conduisons
également sur oeuf lait
et délais de prescription une nouvelle
loi avec bientôt adoptée qui va doubler
tous les dettes prescription c'est très
important pour les victimes des
violences familiales
c'est nous à nous d'aider à nous de
faire la part des choses
à nous de mettre en place tous les
dispositifs qui existent déjà en le
conseil départemental mais qui à mon
sens peut être n'est pas connue n'est
pas assez développée peut-être aussi
deux jours de débats sous forme de
tables rondes qui ont permis d'apporter
des solutions pour lutter contre cette
violence dont sont victimes certaines
femmes réunionnaises